you're listening to the doll up on the
old things comedy network this is a bi
american history podcast for each week i
dave anthony read a story from american
history to my friend
gareth reynolds who has no idea what the
topic
is going to be about back to you at the
intro dave you do though
huh you know what the topic is let's do
it again
you're listening gareth reynolds who
this time is in the second part of a
topic he didn't know
in the first part but since it's a
two-parter now knows what the topic is
going to be about
why are you holding your ear so i can
keep contact with the studio while i'm
also conducting the show with you dave
when's the last time you saw someone
holding their ear when they were
thanks charlie that's right back to you
guys yep
go ahead that hasn't happened since like
the 80s like nobody
more at 11 tonight we'll see you there
again go ahead dave yeah
uh sorry are you time traveling i'm
doing the show i'm
completely present holding your ears and
there's talk of flurries
the ice the the shake the
mcdonald's drink because that's the only
kind we're going to get
we will have a time where people will
only know flurries
from the mcdonald's drink they'll be
like what's a flurry what's a mcflurry
i feel like well it was based on this
thing remember white rain
we laugh because so many people are
going to die back to you guys
in the studio sorry about that dave
anthony got negative
come on oh come on what the [ __ ]
this is where you play the intro and
called it quote
his jam patch champ i'm the [ __ ]
hippo guy dave okay my name's gary
my name's gary is it for fun and this is
not gonna become the tickling podcast
okay
this is like
my friends
how are you we don't need to catch up we
just did an episode
so stop with the sup stuff
oh dave we've got some shoes to talk
about
that's right everybody we make our tour
return
this thursday sorry tuesday september
14th we will be at
wise guys in las vegas then on the 16th
we will be at wise guys in salt lake
city
and then uh we are at the paramount
theater in denver for the high plains
comedy festival
that is uh saturday september 18th join
us there that'll be a great time
september 22nd
uh we will be in phoenix but there's no
ticket link so just get ready
uh then we'll be in san francisco
november 5th saturday november 6th we'll
be in sacramento
december 10th we will be in san diego
and then australia we will be there in
from october to who knows we're not sure
but go to dalekpodcast.com
for all the information there and join
us for some live shows
and then i will be at cb live in phoenix
arizona august 5th that's me gareth
reynolds
i will be at the rally improv august 6th
through the 8th
i will be at hyenas august 19th in
dallas
i'll be at the state theater in austin
texas august 20th
i'll be at the rec room in houston texas
august 21st
spokane comedy club spokane washington
august 26 27th
tacoma comedy club also in washington go
to gareththrones.com
for all the information have you just
been flipping me off the whole time
that's why i don't like doing the camera
stuff you get like
you're like you're not focused you
should be focused on the dates that
i say i'm a pro you are a pro i can't
fight you there
you're a pro i'm a professional how are
you now what are you going to do do you
shout a date for these [ __ ] i just
thought of that um
you know what i should shout the date
and look it up really quick
uh what am i supposed to delay delay
delay oh oh delay
okay you got it hey
everyone uh at the show from the dollop
show that you're listening to
uh just before we jumped in i wanted to
address
something that i think is really
important and this
the topic that we really find crucial
here at the dollop
um the will
we were very curious if waiters and
waitresses will be singing happy
birthday when things are kind of opened
up i mean obviously
corona is now kind of rearing its ugly
head again and it's summer these numbers
shouldn't be that high
but uh if you're at a friday's and you
need to get the
birthday song saying are you gonna get
it
well they'd be wearing masks and why why
come they never sing the regular
birthday song
oh gosh well that's uh something we
needed to
get opened up here at the show and thank
god
we did and that'll be everything that's
all we wanted to talk about
jesus christ dude you're screwing me in
the [ __ ] mouth here
i think i got it um so yeah we're
hopeful they have closure on that soon
so
hey find us on social media uh
i'm at reynoldsgareth dave's at uh big
[ __ ]
and uh and then um let us know your
thoughts
i'm not gonna be a big [ __ ] nobody's
gonna know it's called boomers
nobody's gonna know that that wasn't
meant
to happen like that july 24th
1978. whoa
billy martin fired mm-hmm
disgrace from the yankees uh
george stein in the world series but
getting drunk and saying [ __ ] and
and george steinbrenner getting multiple
death threats death threats
people saying they never go to the game
yankees ex yankees coming out and saying
they're not
never stepped foot in yankee stadium
again people burning tickets outside the
stadium it's [ __ ] man
right the next game after he's fired
it's a home game oh it was still in
season i forgot yeah yeah yeah
and um fans chant we want billy for 20
straight minutes
jesus christ that is the
ability sometimes for fans like that
this like the
person who's always trying to lead the
wave at the games like there's just
certain
you're just sometimes really impressed
by the energy of the lunatic fans yes
100 you know they're amazing yeah uh
reggie didn't play that game and i
assume it's because they didn't
they thought he'd get booed healthy
scratch yeah healthy scratch
mantle ford and other yankees from the
50s team said would never go to the
stadium
billy and george have a meeting so he
calls after if
there's like three or four days go by
and it's like it's like crazy tell that
george steinbrenner is crazy because
if you're gonna make that move you have
to be so
sure that that is going to work out for
you in some way to be on the phone a few
days later just like that
you know yeah shows hey hey
like it's a big whoopsie yeah it's a big
whoopsie that's a big whoopsie
back to you at the studio uh george
tells billy the yankees aren't the
yankees without him and
and and okay so this is
so billy tears streaming down his face
while he got a boner
yeah it was just like a lot was just
like everything's good right now you
said it like that's not normal
no yeah yeah no i know but that's how i
do it yeah yeah
good um so this is
george says he wants him back if he
agrees to only drink beer
what what what a world
what a war it is it's like the idea of
sobriety
was like it wasn't a thing it was just
like
do you remember the ads the the i only
drink beer ads
no okay so i i went online and tried to
find them but i
i really remember these around this time
they had
uh uh they were all these ads on like
please stop being such an alcoholic but
they were basically public service yes
because people
because so much and and there was one
where the guy was like
uh you know i was i was drinking two or
three six packs a day and just thinking
what it's just beer
and that was the ad was like hey beers
alcohol also like it was
the craziest [ __ ] reminding people
that like hey you know
if if you drink a ton of beer then it's
like liquor
numbers wise no no hear me out
[Laughter]
yeah well i mean even as we've heard in
the first part like
the ubiquity of alcoholism
yeah it's like i mean yeah it just it's
crazy yeah
yeah um so he hires billy right there
what the [ __ ] so i hire somebody weirder
five days later
um but he doesn't tell the gm this
what a weird what is like that's why you
don't want to work for these kind of
owners you know what i mean you did what
yeah well i hired your coach back but i
didn't tell the gm so things are pretty
bad and they've already hired another
manager so there's a guy
that they immediately hired i think his
name's bob lemon you got to treat it
like a mistress manager like we were
talking about before
you know don't let him know that's well
okay you ready
no so the gm he tells so george tells
the gm and gm's like well that's [ __ ]
crazy
it's like getting married while you're
married it's like dude you can't you
just hired a guy he hasn't done anything
wrong
i know i messed up in some way i agree
no but we can't then you can't fire that
guy because people are like what are you
doing today i can't fire billy i just
hired billy
you shouldn't have hired billy i agree
but we are where we are i gotta fight
what am i gonna do don't say we
combine them into one person and they'll
share a box i thought you were gonna say
co-manager
oh great co-manager that's even better
that's less science terrible
well if it's bad i'll tell you what i
don't know how we're gonna get him to
share a body
your plan at least like is tethered to
reality in some capacity no just don't
he doesn't come back to
manage all right we should dig up a body
so
are we same paging no okay different
paging
so the gm is like look we keep the guy
we just hired until 1980
and then we bring billy back so we
announce him now
announcements he'll be the new manager
in 1980 so a year and a half away
he'll take over the team what then
everything is resolved because the guy
gets to keep his job for a little while
and
yeah he feels comfortable knowing that
he's coaching for a season and a half
or whatever because i can't no it's like
i'm trying to think of like
like they've got they've had air
appearance like very clearly and
but but you're never like that's right
he's got another season
and a half and then he's done and he's
like what
it's like no matter how good we are what
state the franchise is in
he's out of here we got a new guy coming
in
we're planning ahead oddly now
so they all agree to this they're like
great ideas great okay well it's nice
that we came to the
meet each other in the middle on this
total side thing but the current
manager called everyone meat called
everyone meat so he would walk through
the day and be like how's it going there
meat
hey nice hit me dave i feel physically
ill
i mean a guy
just flippantly calling addressing you
is meat
hey come on here i want to talk to you
me i feel like i'd be like buddy if you
say meat again i'm literally going to
throw up but the fact that that's what's
his
name for everybody is that it's not free
but it's like but like i've
like i say buddy you know what i mean
and it's not great
but it's not me it's meat hey me
thank god that ever caught on so
how are you doing mate you don't
yeah so the next game is alzheimer's day
so that's where the old guys play a game
before right so billy and now they
announced billy at that game as the
future 1980
manager and the crowd goes crazy
seven minutes standing ovation some
people are like what hey that's actually
totally insane
this is really [ __ ] weird it makes no
sense to actually be doing that
because it's not like he's getting
another job so why not just wait and
play this one out and see how it goes a
little bit this
is [ __ ] insane right really strange
move why are we applauding this is crazy
well i mean we're all clapping but it is
very strange it's
crazy [ __ ] strange you should not be
hiring a guy
and then deciding that you're gonna
bring the guy you fired back in like
a year and a half yeah that doesn't make
sense it makes no sense it shows you
that he knows he messed up by firing him
yeah that's right disagree with but i'd
like to see this go through a little bit
but this is [ __ ] up
it's [ __ ] nuts
[Laughter]
uh so reggie asked why he wasn't warned
she's okay uh you know just as a player
this seems like you guys don't know what
you're doing
just from the outside looking in
and george told him quote well i didn't
have to reggie well reggie um here's the
deal
i'm not doing well lately at this don't
give a [ __ ]
yeah reggie would later call this the
worst day of his life
wow really billy
uh billy good life billy apologizes to
george through the press
but he doesn't apologize to reggie right
now
george is a hero too because he brought
he built it back yeah but after fire
it's like somehow it's a pr coup
everyone's happy
except for reggie right but
the press is also stupid to be like
george steinbrenner gets it right
he well reporters are even more stupid
because reporters all
think billy's only going to drink beer
from now on right
it was the idea that that is
in question again it's
i mean not to circle back on it because
i kind of forgot about it but it is just
a crazy stipulation
listen i need you in top form beer only
holy beard low let it be low and bro
uh so that night uh billy goes out and
parties with mantle and ford till 6am
mickey mantle really puts up some
numbers yeah on and off the field
um the yankees win the world series that
year wow
so um it's so awkward i mean still got
another year the other guy still got
another year
honey we're gonna get divorced in two
years and i'm gonna marry sheila
[Music]
no matter how good this goes sheila and
i are gonna
end up in two years that's fair yeah
it's just
the deal i made i'm happy everybody's
happy i [ __ ] her i don't know what
else to do
okay uh reggie became known as mr
october for his playoff heroics
right okay so that would be because
that's when i like
i the highlights that i've seen like
right probably right around them when
he's just [ __ ] cranking
yeah he's cranking the home runs in the
playoffs so
two months later trying to kill the
queen and the naked gun that's right
important stuff so two months later
billy
is in reno he's doing an appearance for
a basketball coach friend like
i think it's a college team or something
but he's like hey you can come in and
help us
yeah he's got like cones with beers and
he's like now see how many of these you
can drink on that cone kid come on
billy's training you so a young local
reporter
interviews billy in a bar and billy [ __ ]
pace
and the reporter asks about a yankee
trade that had happened that day
that billy did not know about now he's
not the coach
he's not the coach but he is the heart
of the organization
he is and like probably has some sort of
position
in the front office or whatever future
coach
so this really pisses billy off sure and
he tries to
get the reporters notes he's like
grabbing at him and trying to snatch the
notes away
because he regrets that he was so drunk
because he
no oh he just hates the information yeah
he's mad so he thinks and
it's it's like he's being sandbagging
he's like oh you're surprising me with
this
right okay and then he punches the
reporter twice in the face
sure okay great so we're two orbital
bones away from the story
that's what that's how you stop an
interview yeah back there
the reporter had uh chipped teeth and a
gash above his eye
i think all the medical expenses were
like 7 500 bucks okay people in other
countries like what are you talking
about
that's right oh we uh we have a great
system where if you get punched in the
face then you will have to pay the
hospital people in this country are also
probably like 7 500
that is an old fee and now
that's not what it looks like now it's
way higher that's right yeah
um so the battered reporters phase
is published in papers across the
country right okay
charges are filed oh you got the
you got the guy yeah oh [ __ ] he he has a
nice shiner um in the picture
and um
the george so the reporter sues
him for you know money on top of it all
face destruction face destruction and
george says billy's fate
was up to the trial outcomes he's like
what happened with the trial
trials that'll be you know what happens
with billy
so there's a lot of
trial i mean george steinberg is again
making it a little weird yes
it's completely insane um the uh oh
my goodness that eyeball is popped
geez he got legitimately popped like
dude his eye looks like a seagulls
or like it's a very strange
i'm more i'm more upset about the mouth
the mouth the mustache is a bother to
begin with yeah the mustache is
upsetting
so so the the the negotiations
are weird because they don't want to
just pay the guy because then it'll make
him seem like he's guilty
so they to they get the medal expenses
paid through the
basketball team that invited him down to
like make it like
seem like he didn't actually do anything
and by the way this is a good thing for
the kids at the
camp to hear about you know you're
trying to instill some lifelong lessons
into these
young go-getters and there's they learn
about the future
sport and how to be a proper sportsman
or sports woman and
um and it's just nice to know that a guy
chipped a reporter's teeth across the
street on a blackout that's right
so what are your coaches um so the
basketball team
ends up paying his medical expenses and
then billy's supposed to
the agreement is billy will apologize at
a press conference to the guy but then
billy's reporter goes up and and says
like oh they agreed on they
everyone says they're sorry and blah
blah and then has them shake hands
and for everybody before billy
apologizes so now that puts the reporter
in a really bad situation he can't be
like
oh you say you're going to apologize
because it looks to everybody like
they've shaken hands and made right
but one i mean i'm not exactly sure
where we're going
but one would assume that billy would
still be like hey i owe this guy an
apology but
billy's like hey all right [ __ ]
cheated you son of a [ __ ]
well billy doesn't think he owes an
apology right but but he agreed
i mean at first billy was like he tried
to punch me but he didn't try to try
right
he threw his eye into my hand i should
have seen this guy
so that's it george afterwards says
billy can sign his new contract
well george steinbrenner feels like a
good guy at the helm
[Music]
are bad again uh and george fires the
manager well before 1980. so billy so
the manager who won the
won the world series is now just like he
does just like he did with billy
it works out really well for
steinbrenner who really was making some
crazy
calls and like oh thank god we suck so
billy's back
and uh he tells right away he's like
reggie's the key to this team
and reggie has to be traded okay
and he just keeps asking to be traded
and george finally says
quote i keep telling reggie that he
should try billy again
the first time i ate broccoli i didn't
like it
the second time i didn't like it now
it's one of my favorite vegetables
it's just i mean seriously
like what are we doing here
what they're called analogies and they
this is a very good one you know that
analogy reminds me of when i was trying
to eat [ __ ]
yes i couldn't do it and uh
i no matter how many times i try it just
won't go down that's right
so yeah that's a good point thanks uh
somehow reggie
took this advice and called billy and
they talked and then ready
billy you're like broccoli you know what
i'm saying
i do yeah yeah thanks thanks reggie i
you know go down
and you're you're like a salmon together
we are
a weird dinner but a good one yeah yeah
sure broccoli and salmon yep
yum
[Laughter]
so reggie comes to play the next day um
now a few months later august 1st
thurman munson died when he crashed his
private plane
okay and he's billy's favorite player
the catcher that was the heartbeat of
the team
yeah yeah billy's just crushed right
well so is thurman to be fair yeah
during a moment of silence before the
next game reggie convulsed in tears in
right field
oh jesus they had such a weird
relationship because i read quotes
but wait wait word and like who was
thurman munson
and reggie and so to his face and they
read you'd be like ha ha like it was all
so [ __ ] weird to read i mean you know
this is the 70s and now it's it's
obviously 40 years later whatever but
it's or 50 years later later
but it's still you reading like wait
what like i i don't know it was just
but so he reggie is creased by yeah he's
upset by it but the [ __ ] thurman
monster hated him i don't know it's just
it's i mean they did they did win
together so who knows what that meant
you know
these guys are yes all over the [ __ ]
maps right um so the yankees don't make
the playoffs that year because
obviously that's tragic uh billy's
divorce from gretchen is finalized
and he meets heather ervolino who is 24
years old and
he looks 16. everyone is like oh my god
billy's dating a
teenager good but good just i was going
to say just
make it look weirders from the outside
things already look
really crazy and not good this will help
yeah those make it as creepy and
hey that old drunk guy is dating a
teenager is that his babysitter
have you seen the yankees coach's new
girlfriend yes she's very young
they become very serious in october goes
to minnesota to hunt with
a friend sure and while he's in a bar
uh-oh never good this feels like this
always sets up poorly for little billy
a marshmallow salesman starts telling
bennett billy his baseball opinion oh
anybody
eat a marshmallow
how are you sir uh just uh curious if
you like snacks
do you like to eat things i do yeah oh
well uh
do you like uh weird consistencies uh
yeah i guess i like would you say you're
open to uncommon luxuries
yeah i love uncommon luxury now as far
as a snack goes
are you open-minded yeah
why then sir allow me to open this
briefcase here and show you what i've
got
look at these things look at that looks
like something you'd put on your door to
stop it from banging into your wall
right
that's a marshmallow you've seen these
before oh yeah
well there's something different about
these what they come with a curse
a what no they don't they're just
regular marshmallows do you want to buy
one
no well then i have a curse why would i
buy a marshmallow out of your suitcase
you don't have to buy one you buy them
in 12s or 24s or 36s
or you can get a marshmallow the month
membership you could become a marsh
member you want to be a march member sir
no that's where every month we don't
know how many marshmallows we're going
to send you
could be none it's 15 a month
have you ever sold any marshmallows sir
are you in or are you out i'm
out well i'm gonna have to ask you to
reconsider have you considered putting
those in bags and selling them
in bags instead of just a lot of bags
that's a lot of overhead when it comes
to the bag budget which we don't have
nobody wants loose marshmallows well i
mean it's mixed in with some of my cards
and pens because i'm not what am i going
to carry two briefcases
yes well that sounds like now now who's
great now who's sounding crazy
no these are still you look sir just
shut the [ __ ] up for a minute and listen
to me
do you have any interest in buying a
bunch of these marshmallows no
i have more in the car i where in the
car in the front seat in the front seat
yes
sitting there in a pile i mean
you know yeah yes there's a bunch of
them yes in a pile
well i can't put them all in the
briefcase with my pencils why aren't
they in bags
i don't sir i'm not gonna sit here again
and break down the bag budget
all right i can't believe you've never
met a marshmallow salesman before you
acted like that's crazy
it's crazy it's not i sell
marshmallows you can just go to a store
and buy them why do that when i'm right
here offering you a great package
i don't want i don't want to be around
you i don't nobody does
karen left
so this marshmallow salesman starts
telling billy his baseball beans
you know when you sell marshmallows
door-to-door you have a lot of time to
think
baseball captures my thoughts
including talking about how bad the
yankees were that year
billy finally quote oh no
tell you what joe i bet you 500 your
penny that i can knock you on your ass
and he put 500
on the bar
the marshmallow salesman quote let's go
[Laughter]
i love the marshmallow salesman as they
walked out
billy punched him in the mouth oh jesus
the hotel police were called um
the billy told so then the hotel police
like the next day or whatever tell the
press that gets out
billy tells the press the salesman fell
and cut his lip
you know these marshmallow salesmen are
they're always falling
that's why they work in such soft
materials george didn't believe billy
and he launches an investigation
five days later billy is fired as
yankees manager
so the tenure was what i don't know
like not weeks not no it's it's it's a
long time because they
he made it into the next season okay so
so about a season probably
yeah more if not less okay maybe less
okay but still okay well no it's about a
season because it's after
no i mean marshmallow salesman's in a
bar during the day
shows you how good the job was going i
mean look that's just what i mean
if you've ever read the the marshmallow
salesman chronicles it's not
yeah it's dark yeah it's very dark
so yeah so he's fired he billy billy is
what year is this this is uh 79.
a marshmallow salesman i think it's 80.
so
uh billy goes back to california and
hanging out with his family he's very
despondent very upset
and he's resenting george because he had
followed all of georgia's rules yeah he
only stuck to beer
he got along with reggie no problems
with the press no problems with george
you didn't tell me i couldn't whoop a
marshmallow salesman's ass
you should have put that in the contract
well now i know
don't ruin marshmallow salesman
so he thinks the fight thing is just a
random
unrelated event it has nothing to do
with the yankees i wasn't
a coach when i beat up the market i had
my hat on i didn't have my uniform on
hey plus if you can't beat up a
marshmallow salesman what are we doing
we need to get rid of them now the oath
in oakland oathlon the oakland athletics
are a terrible team right they've lost
108 games the last year
sports writers called them the oakland
pathetics sure
so i'm going to call those sports
writers pathetics
yes um there's about are they getting
about 3 700
fans of games wow and they're and
they're just like so you could get a row
they're four years off being one of the
best teams of all time right you know so
um they immediately hired billy two-year
contract
125 000 his wife his wife his sister
says she's very relaxed and happy again
because it's his hometown right right um
so
he told the a's gets a team together and
he goes look you guys
you guys are going to steal home eight
times this year
but stealing home is crazy yeah like
you'd be lucky if eighteen
eight teams did it right it's just an
insane thing to say
he and they told ricky henderson quote
you're going to break ty cobb's record
for stolen bases in a season
ricky's brand new in the league and he's
like but that's [ __ ] crazy
ricky was born and raised in oakland um
he didn't speak great
so people didn't realize he was a
baseball genius
and and he said to billy quote that's 96
bases skip
and billy said quote we don't stop until
you've got at least a hundred
and billy quickly taught the a's how to
rattle opponents like he'd done before
right
and this is when it became known as
billy ball
okay um oh i thought that was a picture
it's just me
what's the picture no it's very pretty
thank you they stole home nine times
that
season stealing home is so hard because
like if you're gonna steal
first to second the pitcher's got like
you're not in his field of vision but if
you're on third base
the whole idea is there's something
called the bach if you bock
the the backing is like you don't come
to a complete stop
when you're pitching right start going
again or right or you step the wrong way
there's like a bunch of ways you can
block but so you have to be very
very strict and regimented when you're
pitching and if you go off a little bit
the player gets an extra base so the
whole reason one of the reasons to do
that
is to rattle the pitcher so he might
block
right it just [ __ ] with his mind like
he sees you running he has to keep his
motion the same
right but it throws it right right
so yeah so nine times is crazy they
stole home twice in one inning
so hey so fans are just going this is
just [ __ ] amazing right fans are
going crazy
they're doing hidden ball tricks they're
throwing balls in the dirt to scuff it
so the pitcher can then use it to
you know throw better they learn how to
throw spit balls
ricky is stealing bases like crazy game
attendance goes up
from 3 700 to 12 000. okay
ricky quote the other team starts
grousing and complaining they're half
angry and half embarrassed and we're
smiling i tell you it was fun so they're
having a
[ __ ] blast billy and ricky have a
bond
uh he's also being from oakland he takes
care of ricky
and ricky's odd okay ricky's not dude he
he calls other players by nicknames meat
not meat but
just everyone he gives a nickname to and
a few of his teammates thought it was
because he didn't know their names
right that's a good move
i mean you got to be good with those
nicknames that's a good move one example
is later in his career he's on a new
team and
there's a teammate there that you know
he just started and
the teammate has a batting helmet on and
he goes helmet it's john oliver he goes
he asked me if he always wore the helmet
in the field he does because
the guy wears it in the field when he's
on defense
and uh he says quote we had a guy on the
mets last year who did that too
and all the road says quote yeah ricky
that was me
i was your teammate for all year and i
wore the helmet so
yeah that hurts ricky wants gotta also
he wore the helmet in the eye
he got hit in the head so if he got hit
in the head again he would die so he had
to wear
okay don't make me feel better yeah i'd
see you really just
asking a question yeah you're like a
marshmallow i gotta be honest that's
unbelievable
so ricky halos one time ricky got a one
million dollar bonus at the end of the
season
and after a few months the team called
because the check hadn't been cashed
and ricky had framed it and put it on
his wall wow
well with like a break in case some
emergency glass or something i don't
know
wow that's amazing that's like you do
that with the one your first one dollar
bill or whatever
look he also goes on to be the best lead
offender in major league baseball
history like he's
amazing so billy hung out at the
danville hotel
in a bar where no one bothered him like
it's his new bottom of the barrel right
right but on the road the fights with
the marshmallow salesman
and the young reporter gave him a rep
right
so before he was battling billy who
fought on the field and was a tough guy
and now he's known
as a drunk bar fighter okay
so he was a marked man just like back in
the day in berkeley
drunks want to take on the most famous
bar brawler in america
billy quote it would escalate the guy
would say did you get fired today or
why don't you take a swing at me come on
you don't look so tough
billy's son who's older now billy signed
quote i watched hundreds of big bruising
guys come up to my dad in a bar and say
they're going to kick his little ass
i'm telling you it never stopped i'm no
i'm no marshmallow salesman billy why
don't you try
beating me up i mean i it is important
that we celebrate the marshmallow
throughout the story and keep his memory
alive
um for yeah future generations
oh my god um i'm not no marshmallow
sales it's like yeah
no one else is that was the only one
ever there was never another marshmallow
salesman
another uh quote i remember one night
the guy sitting next to him just kept
flicking his
cigarette ashes on billy's arm and hand
billy kept asking him to stop but the
guy just stared at him and kept flicking
the ashes on him
i saw a guy kick another guy's ass for
ashing on him a few times
and it was uh everyone was like you are
within your rights
but so he is as much as he's the brawler
he also is holding back
holding back like he's not on the road
fans began to pelt him
with marshmallows oh no
mo i mean the marshmallow guy had to be
at home like that's right you son of a
[ __ ]
you beat me up but i made millions
marsh millions wow
but but if you're going to have things
thrown at you
yeah there's not a lot of better things
i would just open my mouth
yeah right and i think he's eating all
of them
in minnesota hundreds of people during a
loss through marshmallows at billy so
they're just
right in but in new york fans gave him
again a standing ovation they still
loved him
he was named manager of the year for
improving the a's record by 29 wins
with the exact same players they didn't
wow get a new player crazy same team
29 more wins uh they drew 500 000 more
fans wow
the a's gave him a five-year contract
yeah i was gonna say
the next spring training a british rock
star photographer who hung out with the
stones and the who
came to take pictures of the team that's
right
everyone yes you know that household
just not the right vibe for the
environment what you've got those silly
little bats and things
move that out the way come on everyone
get on the drummies
kick a soccer ball there you are yeah
quote i've been around a lot of crazy
[ __ ]
but billy his coaches and some of the
players
they kept up to that level it was all
alcohol-based
but some of these older guys were
serious
professional drinkers some mornings at
the batting cage in spring training with
the coaches staying there it didn't
smell like alcohol it smelled like
someone had dumped a quart of gym beam
on home plate
wow so they are just [ __ ] wow
what a crazy what a crazy
i mean it's just like so counter to what
you would think
an athletic organ i mean it's just you
know
yeah yeah let's invite impairment into
every level of this
i mean that's [ __ ] yes
so that the a started that season with a
17-1 record
and they're drunk and yeah and the
coaches are and they're [ __ ]
and then this is mike norris who is on
the bees the coke
of coke this is like as long as they
have some cocaine i didn't know they had
cocaine too probably
time magazine put billy on the cover
under it the headline it's
incredible so he's on time magazine's
cover because it's just
you'd just be like we need to drink more
we're doing so good
can we get ivs yeah it's just vodka
and marshmallows but in may
billy was suspended a week for bumping
an umpire now the empire's union were
done with billy
that's called bumper by the bump hiring
the umpires union
were considering suing billy for assault
okay
another um called billy quote probably
the meanest
most unfair man of all on the field
okay now heather's living in his house
in uh gated blackwater
with her brother [ __ ] so uh what
how can i scream
explain black black water is like a
crazy [ __ ] rich
housing place that is walled off
and it's in the east bay and it's like
just super [ __ ] rich people okay so
he's
she's living there uh with her brother
mother and grandmother
at his house and i can't really figure
this out like so we all he's everyone
he's
he's living there but he's not like he'd
also stay at the
hotels like it's it's weird okay
um and it's weird to move in every
member of that is also weird but she
didn't want to go without her family so
and you know if you saw
if you saw a blackhawk you'd be like all
right right yeah okay
in july 1980 he meets jill
gwiver who's a 25 year old photographer
oh dear
oh billy oh bill uh they're very soon
inseparable okay
that's going to be a problem because
well he's separable with someone else
right now
i'm sorry he's an inseparable thing
already he can't be
yeah but this is a different person oh
right no i think that still my point
still
stands that um no she's a different
so he can be yeah but he's got the one
so you can't be inseparable
and carry on two relationships oh well
hold on
oh she was his road girlfriend well
touche friend billy thought
he had better morals than his players
who had one night stands on the road
disgusting get yourself a road wife he
probably told an aids executive that he
only had one woman on the road and one
at home
i keep it pretty good where i come from
i'm not looking for any stress or drama
the a's made the playoffs uh-huh but
then
good for road wife oh yeah more at a
time
but then they lost the yankees in four
games okay after
at the after party yankee greg nettles
decked reggie jackson
okay
and they won reggie's just awful
yeah [ __ ] awful yeah billy
was now more famous than ever sure
billy ball was trademarked um the t
got team got most of the profits but
it's trademarked he had tons of
endorsements
sears wants to now sell a billy martin
casual wear line oh my god he dressed in
like cowboy
it's one pant legs off okay
it's gonna be tons of [ __ ] money like
this is like this is striking it rich
right
so sears sends a private jet to bring
him to a meeting
at their headquarters okay unfortunately
the jet had scotch on it so billy showed
up wasted and they canceled the deal
okay
good good good good good good smart
that's fine it's okay he could have used
it because in late 1981 the irs said
billy owed two hundred thousand dollars
in back taxes what the hell's a back tax
he didn't say anything the year it
happened i told you remember
when i told you i said you have to pay
taxes on these checks you're depositing
they were for commercial things it
doesn't matter i tried to explain this
to you it wasn't me i was pretending to
be
someone else no no no no that's not how
it works you got money as billy martin
all right well look
just tell them i now know
tell them them yeah who irs
just tell them you know now i get it
right but you still owe money like
oh [ __ ] they didn't tell me anything no
they didn't have to everybody knows that
that's why i told you i told you i was
like you gotta pay taxes
all right tell them this
they owe me money
let's go at him
[Laughter]
uh so he's very distracted by his money
problems sure and he's very distant
they had scotch on that plane huh he's
very distant in spring training that
year
that's good for a coach right yes he had
a trailer
outside the left field fence and he just
stayed in it for hours
no that's good that's how you can coach
yeah for sure just treat it like a
like a tornado unit that's right like a
twister van yeah
uh the players all feel abandoned and
then that year because their coach lives
in rv outside outside the wall yeah
it's not great yeah so the pitchers all
start falling apart that year
and they'd been the key to 1981 but now
they all
they all had injuries and people started
blaming billy and the pitching coach for
using them too much the year before
okay overusing them so they're saying
it's his fault and
and one day that season after they'd
lose enough games billy
comes into his office and just [ __ ]
destroys it okay billy ball tv fridge
desk wall watch spelling machine wow
i mean he literally destroys the they
try to fix it
overnight sure so the owners don't find
out but the owners find out
right and they start thinking billy's a
little unhinged why because he ruined
the office
or even outlets right okay stuck right
so after this season they fire him okay
now in november billy's in manhattan
with jill
and a photographer takes a picture of
them standing very close
and it goes in the paper and billy flips
the [ __ ] out sure and
he's like i gotta call heather and he
calls heather
and he proposes to her what the [ __ ]
dudes are just so
crazy dudes are just crazy
they are crazy there's no like
the whole situation is nuts but
like the level of insanity gets himself
to
just being like if she sees it she'll
like the fear that
the relationship can generate in a guy
like he's
completely acting out of fear and it's
just a picture where they're not
standing like super far away from each
other you could make up any reason
yeah or at least let her start it be
like hey i saw a picture of the paper
but instead he's like
honey look i got something to tell you i
have to marry you
wow so they get
married in the same month
that he proposed in new orleans like a
couple weeks later they get married
okay jill is still his road lady though
road lady but she didn't know he got
married well of course not
that's not on the road
now george george gone through three
managers that year alone
oh my god are they gonna yankees
finished fifth no
george hires billy again as manager in
january wow
third time can't quit him at the first
home game 55 000 fans cheer
and the marketing campaign is billy is
back right
team not good sure george had told
reporters he wouldn't interfere with the
team
until halfway through the season he said
he wouldn't that was his
uh he said i won't interfere
intelligence just when it gets important
then i'll start
messing with it i'm not gonna start
[ __ ] with anything until until
halfway through and then i'm gonna
really just
[ __ ] everybody get crazy it's so
uh in may he he can't help himself he
doesn't make it to halfway through the
season in may
he goes into the clubhouse and he scolds
the team and just tears into him
after he leaves billy tells the player
you just [ __ ] ignore him and the
players all laugh
on july 24th the yankees are playing the
kansas city royals
and their best player george brett
hits a game-winning home run in the
final at bat okay
and the entire team is celebrating and
as they are billy strolls out to the
umpire at home plate
and asked him to check the bat to see if
it was illegal
so players could put something called
pine tar on the bats on the back
so the hand the handle where you're
right right yeah a grip sticky right
and uh it couldn't be above 18 inches
because they didn't want pine tarp
getting on the ball
right right
so billy's request is not really what
it's intended for it's not about hitting
it
it's about pine tar it's about pine tar
so you would
normally be like hey it's getting sticky
stuff on the ball
when billy makes his request brett yells
from the dugout quote
if they call me out you're going to see
four dead umpires
jesus brett learn how to talk [ __ ]
we don't get there right away yeah it's
just like
early aggressive be open
and they call him out wow okay
because of the pine tar yeah brett loses
his [ __ ] mind well he better be
killing four umpires otherwise he
doesn't hold to his word
yeah and he storms out of the dugout
like a madman to try to get at the
empire another empire is to grab him by
the neck to hold him back i mean he is
he's a [ __ ] madman okay
now the yankees finished that's that's
one of the biggest moments in baseball
history like everyone knows that moment
um yeah but they just know george brett
no one is no one realizes that on the
other side of it is billy martin being
his little [ __ ]
genius right you know is that why is it
famous just because it's [ __ ]
it's famous because of george bett's
reaction oh okay right going crazy
okay yeah yeah there is traffic yeah no
there's definitely
there's like i like the way that i like
the guy there's a lady down there just
yay
yeah but it's also there's one two three
they're standing on a line like
don't worry we'll defend him in a line
yeah
so the yankees finished that season 91
and 71 which is a really [ __ ] great
record but not enough of the playoffs
back right
um and then george fire sure
[Applause]
whatever well he did fire him he
replaced him with yogi berra
but he made sure everyone knew billy
wasn't fired just moved
to a new position advisor for trades and
personnel quote
i don't like to talk about firing
managers i don't fire them
i re-house them yeah so he's very after
the past
time at times of firing billy he really
doesn't want to
get into it and so he's like no i did i
did he's not fired
he's he's new hired he's just not there
he's different job
he's in another office with another name
plate at the beginning of the next
season jill is on a plane when a yankee
wife
asked her quote so what are you doing
now that billy's married and that's how
jill found out billy was married i can't
believe
that that's crazy like crazy
she goes back to newport beach and billy
flies there and they get into a huge
fight on her lawn
and the cops are called and billy is
arrested for public
public drunkenness and disorderly
conduct okay good
so now his wife heather yes
well the new york times headline quote
martin jailed as drunk
the papers were harsher than they had
ever been before because new younger
reporters didn't understand why billy
hadn't always been reported on as a
drunk [ __ ]
right so there's this change in culture
media and culture and they're like what
the [ __ ] you what's with this drunk guy
that you're all
you know acting like he's awesome he
just drinks beer
so worked up about
i don't know why but one one i think was
the ap reported that they had fought
over a horse and that must have been to
cover for him
because they would cover for ball
players bachelor sure
they fought over a horse they had a
horse fight come on
that happens billy told jelly was gonna
leave heather
and in a year they did they divorced um
jill
look i want you to get your stuff and
get out of here and that goes for your
mom your dad and your grandma too
whoops so crazy
jill and billy became closer but his
friends and family did not like jill
okay nobody liked jill sure they felt
like jill pushed them all away from
billy
okay she didn't approve of his drinking
outings with his buddies and she didn't
like the hunting trip
like that the family's like you're
trying to change him he's a full-on
alcoholic he's been as a drinking
problem like quit trying to take the
billy out of billy
the next season the yankees start six
and ten and yogi berra was fired and
billy was named
manager of the new york times i did not
know that george steinbrenner was like
this career like
i knew he was crazy i've enjoyed
seinfeld and this steinbrenner
impression have been like yeah he's nuts
i mean it seemed nuts
but this is nuts this is like a guy
who's like how do you get famous from
firing people
i know how he's really out of his
[ __ ] mind crazy
that like i mean you just give a guy
like 11 games and then be like no you're
done
yeah i mean it just and how many times
can you fire and hire the same [ __ ]
guy
yeah you know i should hire don't say
billy billy
but now fans weren't happy because of
how yogi bear was fired you don't fire a
guy
16 games into a [ __ ] season that's
crazy
there's 162 [ __ ] games yeah
also they were like how many times is
billy gonna get hired people
people are disgusted with how george
runs the team and for the first time
when billy was announced it was just a
quick ovation and also for the first
time so
random booing yeah okay late that season
they're in a race to win the division
and it's like this is like 10 days
of maybe the worst 10 days in yankee
history
so they have a bad series against the
top team
and then george shows up in the press
box the next game
and he starts reading the stats of
several yankees from that series that
didn't do well
reading where of his play in the press
box with all the press
okay griffey 048 baylor 0 for 7
winfield 3 for 11. quote where's rezzy
where's reggie jackson we need a mr
october or mr
september winfield is mr may the big
guys are not coming through the guys who
are supposed to carry the team
are not carrying the team good
so good good so that's motivation that's
how you run a team
yes this became known as george's mr
may speech for some reason the team is
[ __ ] pissed
what happened well i don't know i didn't
that he's just [ __ ] on the personnel
to the people who write about it
and particularly dave winfield because
dave wouldn't feel there's a guy who
would just like run
full force into the fence to catch the
ball like he just gave it his all right
and he went three for 11 which isn't
[ __ ] terrible like that's like three
for
that's like a good that's a good series
right um
so the next day george said quote
if they're not embarrassed they should
take the uniform off and walk away from
the pay window
okay so he doubled down yankees are more
pissed
a couple days later billy asks a
right-handed batter
to hit left-handed the guy been the guy
never hit left-handed before but he
started practicing trying to hit
left-handed and so billy was like
hit left-handed he strikes out
they lose that game and people think
billy's gone absolutely [ __ ] crazy
yeah
now the lanky and he's lost six the
yankees have
lost six in a row and they were in
contention to win the division
and then there's this pitcher on the
team that no one likes
he's a redneck guy named ed whitson the
players hate ed
the fans hate ed he's you know the fans
jeer at him and booit him like nobody
[ __ ] likes ed
he's so bad under pressure so
they're in this six game losing streak
and billy's like i cannot have [ __ ]
head wits in pitch
so he bailey am i starting today
[Applause]
um i feel good i just gotta get a couple
pitches out just get my arm loose
and then i'll be ready there's water out
there right or can i call for
there's no water boy marshmallows
oh we have a contract i understand i
respect
um so billy tells instead of just saying
he's not good
at under pressure billy says well his
arms hurt okay
so then the press goes to ask ed and
it's like no my
arm's not [ __ ] hurt my arm's fine
ego's killing me yeah and now ed's
[ __ ] furious
so after the game the players are at a
if you can imagine at a bar yeah
first time charity stuff quote
whitson was agitated and talking loudly
about billy martin
and then whitson starts arguing with a
guy at a table next to him
okay just some random dude sure and they
get into it and they stand up and they
get in each other's faces
and ed grabs him by the throat now ed
knows martial arts
so he grabs the guy by the throat they
always say you're not supposed to use
that unless you're drunk
that's right and billy comes running
over to stop it
let me beat his ass and he gets in
between them
and he says quote eddie you're drunk you
don't need this and then
eddie called billy a [ __ ] and
punched him
for billy this must have been very
strange wait a minute
that's me normally so now they start
fighting
okay and sports writers are there
watching and just taking notes first
thing i try to do is hurt his arm to be
like told ya
see can't bend it ed is out of his
[ __ ] mind screaming throwing punches
they get separated and they lead them
through the lobby to take them up to
their separate rooms
it's pretty amazing that one's the coach
[Laughter]
now it's so crazy that they have us they
have his arms pinned to his side as they
walk
him okay but he breaks free
and he kicks billy in the balls so hard
and lifts billy off the ground oh my god
what no this is like mel brooks like
this is
i mean that's possible yeah to kick a
guy's
ball so hard he flies
yeah it's a thing oh my god
billy it billy crumples to the ground ow
and then he stands up and he takes he
spits his nuts out he takes a deep
breath
and he looks at ed and he says quote now
i'm gonna have to kill you
oh my god i mean if a guy kicks your nut
so hard you go
off the ground you have to come back
with some heat he knows he knows you
gotta counter punch
now i'm afraid i'm gonna have to kill
you you understand
ed is pushed out of the lobby as billy
comes after him
so the way this is described it is
described like a crazy
monkey dodging everybody tries to block
him billy yeah
billy is now people are trying to keep
him blind see there's some people who
would
crumble at the pain of the ball kick but
billy somehow
harnesses and he takes the fire into his
belly and his fists and now he needs to
just get it out that's what makes me
strong
okay come again so so he's just
dodging and faking and weaving
and he gets past the last guy
oh my god and now there's a group of
players who are surrounding ed trying to
move him away and billy rushes at
the group and they start trying to punch
each other over everybody
and then everybody falls over in a giant
pile
billy hits his head on the ground the
back of his head hits the pavement and
so he's dazed
so they grab billy and take him back to
the lobby
they take ed over to the parking lot
and then they take belly to a bill
billy to a back elevator and they take
him up to the third floor
and as the doors open the other guys no
got ed right there hey we're just gonna
put eddie oh [ __ ]
[Laughter]
round four no more so
yeah so they go at each other again and
uh and they finally get them separated
for
the final the all the fighting 25
minutes oh my god
and an elevator ride yeah an elevator
ride
george hears about it the next morning
i'm gonna hire eddie to be the new
manager
how do you think about that everybody
george
[Laughter]
billy has a broken arm cuts on his face
and
back before the game reporters asked
billy what happened to his arm
quote i heard it bowling you know how
bowling is
those pins shatter so george conducts
another investigation
and then he announces neither guy's
going to be punished okay nobody this
one was fine sure george whatever you
want to do
he's like billy wasn't looking for a
fight he was trying to stop a fight and
but
i don't know why he doesn't punish ed ed
hit him first that was going to fight
with it
sure well here's the reason because he's
not really mad about the fight
he likes it well he had set a curfew for
12 p.m and he's now furious that the
players were
out drinking in the bar after midnight
okay george you do you baby you do you
for the rest of his life ed never spoke
of the fight okay wow
oh jesus the yankees did not make the
playoffs but again they finished
97 and 64. again
amazing record jeez yeah so he's got a
broken arm there
good lord and look how old he looks like
yeah he's an old guy look at the
dan akroyd cop behind him that guy's not
uh enforcing much
certainly not so look that's an amazing
record
still not enough to make the playoffs
because somebody was better but
everyone's excited about the next season
sure people are optimistic billy gives
i guess it was tradition for at the last
game for the
the manager to give a summary of the
season in front of the players and
reporters
okay so he did and during that he says
he wants a race
he wants a race yeah during the he
explains how
the summer of the season how great it
went and then he says i want to race
that's why i got fired before oh right
okay sorry
turns out the irs had put a lien on his
salary
oh a raise raise yeah okay what do you
think race
oh no oh yeah he wants to race ed
whitson okay good
that's how the sausage at county stadium
um okay
rumors quickly start that ex-yankee lou
pinella would replace him
now billy does not go back to heather
after the season or even talk to her
he just she'll figure it out
this whole thing of having to
communicate the end
it's not necessary people figure it out
true
if you just go away forever she'll
figure it out
how hard can it be she's what she's
doesn't have the power of deduction
she'll notice
she files for divorce the court papers
the divorce court papers said he did not
come home after the 1985 season yeah and
she and what happened she got it he
figured it out
figured it out and
lou pinella was made the new manager
okay
and then fired nine days into the season
this is the crazy
parrot it must have just been because he
asked for a raise because he
97 and 64 is an amazing record well
i mean he did he did get into a fight
with it yeah he had like a family guy
fight with one of the players so it's
sort of like
you know i mean i don't know
so uh pinellas new manager billy is not
fired he has moved to baseball assistant
to george which is a totally vague
made-up job that's a great job now you
can work for him directly
literally never been glean all the
information that steinbrenner doesn't
have off of that
it's just a totally not real thing yeah
papers are now using roman numerals for
billy's manager stints
billy uh iv was over is it ivy or
1v well that would yeah sure
but george gave billy a big raise and
wiped out a loan that he'd given him 150
000 so he's still like taking care of
him yeah it's weird
billy and jill got engaged friends and
family
were very upset she took over his
finances she worked his pr
the next season the yankees had a billy
martin day and they retired his number
until they rehired him later that
afternoon
his family came uh to yankee stadium for
the first and only time
and while they were there they fought
with jill for the entire that's crazy
that's the first time they've ever been
isn't that yeah that's really weird um
billy said to the fans quote i may not
have been the best yankee to put on the
pinstripes but i am the proudest that's
like a huge
quote that people say so as divorce
from heather's finalized his drinking
eases up a bit he has a very quiet
season
and then october george announces billy
is back his manager
and
he retired his number he retired his
number
how you know what i mean he retired his
your coach under a different number god
damn it
[Laughter]
wow five v
billy martin yankees five
that's crazy uh this time i think we'll
figure out if he's right or not and not
over like 20 years like no
this is like just five years five years
so uh pinellas moved to gm
i mean the pinellas the g's like steimer
is like that's what we need
he'll be the gm instead that's better
and i'll be my own assistant god damn it
billy marries jill at a huge wedding the
night before the wedding
his friends tried to talk him out of
marrying her that's not always nice
that's my favorite part of a wedding the
night before when you try to get the guy
to bail [ __ ] do this man
she's a i just don't want to lose you
yeah what the [ __ ] man it's been nice to
see everybody but come on
um so on may 6th they played a game in
texas and
afterwards billy mickey mantle and a
couple other guys that's good but
already i got a good
feeling got a good feeling go out
drinking i got a good feeling
they end up at a strip club called lace
lace
nice mickey gets so drunk that the other
two guys have to escort him home
i can't walk okay
billy was left there billy was never
supposed to be left alone
oh god this is a manager
he should be very comfortable alone
so he's taking a leak in the bathroom
and he's at the urinal
that's good at least two guys come in
and one hits him on the head with
something
okay probably blackjack like they hit
him with something really [ __ ] hard
i've never been jumped like that before
i was still standing there peeing
i had my deal still out
and i wanted a raise
so he's knocked down just kicked and
punched
and then they they drag him out the back
door
and they take his head oh jesus and they
drag it across
the jagged stucco wall of the building
outside
god quote the ear was all but sheared
off oh my god they stuck out his ear off
yeah jesus christ
at the hotel the yankee
crew the players the team organ
there's a bunch of people there and
someone pulled the fire alarm so
everyone's outside
okay the hotel by the way shout out to
the prankster good one
always always a great prank george is in
a silk robe
of course he should look like a worm
a cab rolls up billy rolls out
covered in blood holding a jacket
to his just bloody ears
wow okay so george is like okay this is
good
yeah so everyone my ear's coming in
another ride that's why i hired you yeah
what yeah nevermind we'll talk
later we'll talk later later yeah yeah
i'll talk to you later
they take it to ireland hospital he
needs 50 stitches he has a swollen eye a
gash on his cheek huge bruises
the ear contusion on the back of his
skull like he's really [ __ ] up yeah
billy told reporters caught i just feel
embarrassed because i got caught off
guard
i didn't think i'd get hit in the head
in the toilet it's fair
fair fair that's like holy ground like
you should be
like you shouldn't be able to attack a
guy at a urinal no that's true
the police said billy it did absolutely
nothing to provoke it
george said he was the victim but we're
firing him anyway
that's it for you because it's correct
cause i'm crazy
the next day billy's in the dugout the
players are amazed
and horrified one of them said quote
he was really messed up this time there
was blood caked in his ear and along the
stitches
it was kind of scary oh my gosh
hey skip frankenstein um
oh my god blood cake the blood cake like
that's here's the deal
wash it well until you're until it's
coming out from being able to wash or
you know with time then you can go back
it's not the time to be working if you
have the dried blood i think back then
you couldn't get stitches wet right
probably that would not surprise me by
the way what a great face
oh don't let these get wet
it feels like a movie plot now
so they go back to new york and
reporters are [ __ ]
horrified by his appearance sure and the
fact that it happened
in a strip club made it all worse right
yeah his rep takes another big hit
george quote he's a six-year-old man and
when i saw his ear was hanging
he shouldn't have been there he has to
use better judgment
yeah that's true yeah that is it's weird
it's not a good look
so a little while after this they're in
oakland
and the ump makes a bad call and billy
charges out rips his ear off and throws
it at him
take that you son of a [ __ ] he charges
out and he tries to throw
dirt on him but that it's hard clay
so he gets down i'm gonna make him a vod
he gets down on the ground oh i've seen
this
and he tries to shovel it right and it
just
looks it's embarrassing yeah it looks
it's like a kidney
you can't like get enough dirt and it's
just it's
it's weird and sad right
writers are not kind the new york times
asked sports psychologists for opinions
of
billy's display in oakland one quote
dirt adds another quality
filth ultimately meaning contempt it's
an expression of contempt so they're
just
yeah no [ __ ] and what he's expressing
here is displeasure
he the the dirt adds an element he's
basically essentially
consciously unconsciously saying to the
officiant
that he does not believe in what he
is saying is law and he's doing that by
analogizing the soil to the
consistency of the calls
so it's nuanced it's difficult to read
it's a bit like a rosetta stone
situation
because he was kicking dirt out of it he
is telling him through
action the dirt is my expression of
displeasure
which is strong you're i paid a lot of
money
which is why i am forming this uh sort
of triangulation here
of the clay um near your appendages it's
my way of saying this is a roadblock
i'm not into this it is dirty it is
filthy it is below me
um and he's sort of we've never seen
anything quite like it has anybody tried
to kill
you oh yeah yes absolutely i used to
sell marshmallows but so and we
we have made it into this pile and it's
uh
it's it's it's an objection um but it's
also
a way of sending a message uh
discounting the
opinion and um and i would like to die
yes yeah well it's uh that's how that's
how the efficient probably felt at
the moment um but it's very nuanced
again and not a layman is not going to
be a wakey wakey
a layman is not going to be able to uh
pick up on something like this that's
a good thing you brought me in for that
so
that'll be hundred 800 dollars
please billy was suspended for three
games
and the empires were pissed they wanted
a lot more sure
the empire's union said billy wouldn't
be allowed to leave the dugout quote
it's kind of like they're legal like we
technically have jurisdiction over the
field
yeah i know right quote he's going to
have to fold his hands
shut his mouth and that's it otherwise
he's going to be ejected ejected ejected
ejected every time
for the next couple of weeks that he
comes out of the dugout he'll be ejected
this is the weakest threat
he better follow the rules and if
we're going to give him a couple weeks
where he has to so they ejected him
every time he came out and dug out so
he's still coming out
he essentially can't do his job right i
mean the manager has to come out of the
dugout like he can't
usually does he yeah there's times you
have to go out the pitcher sometimes
but i always feel like those are
[ __ ] conversations i mean
essentially he's going like you think he
could still do it the guy's like yeah
and he's like man i think he can get out
of here
so now because the umpires are riding
billy george starts taking shots at
billy again
right of course george and the team's
doing well the team's doing
that's irrelevant george is just
georgia turns out is upset because he
ordered the pitchers to do
a specific training program every day
but then the team
ignored it right because again he has no
connection to athletics
and no understanding of reality so he he
goes to pinella and he goes i'm going to
hire
i'm going to get rid of billy again can
you be coach and pennell's like i don't
want to be like billy you keep hiring
and be hiring no no then he'll be the gm
but then then he's like well then i'm
going to order this i'm going to hire
this guy who's outside the inking
organization and pinella's like oh you
can't hire a non-yankee yeah it's not
no no no no that's um i don't even know
how that would work
what's that going to look like so
pinellas takes the job and
george is fired as yankee and um
billy is fired billy's fires sorry
billy's fired
yeah it's the 15th yankee manager in
15 years wow that is something and
they've won a lot of championships and
they their record they have these 97
91 wins like those are crazy good
seasons for a baseball team
billy didn't hear about it from george
his lawyer called him right right
he's in shock as are the fans because
the team was [ __ ] doing well
they had a 40 and 28 record wow
fourth best in major league baseball
fans
attack george on talk radio i think
george maybe just as a fetishist
[Laughter]
other people however say billy needs
rehab right they're like well this guy
needs help
most are worried about him george
george still keeps him on the yankee
payroll he still got a position
advisor or whatever so
he goes in and meets with george a month
later george is very remorseful
but probably because the yankees were
not
they immediately were bad as soon as he
was not managing they were
good dave he he better not be [ __ ]
hunting no no
how could that happen how could that i
mean he's about to hire him again
george gives him a raise okay okay yeah
you deserve more money for not really
being in the round
so a billion jail moved to a farm in
upstate new york
they uh they installed the 24 karat
gold-plated urinal in the bathroom
because billy missed the toilet
so often late at night he's probably
looking for people to be hammering him
in the head every time he goes now he's
got
bathroom ptsd yeah yeah he's got p t
t well done they had a sheep a ram
geese ducks billy putters around a
tractor
jilly walls off billy completely from
his family's friends okay
yankees finished in fifth place okay
but he's living a small town life and
he's he's liking it right he goes and
does an occasional
appearance yeah and sure every now and
then he'd go like murder a stranger in
the woods or something just to get the
feeling again
he's still a team advisor he talks to
george on the phone
george fires lou penelo and hires dallas
green who's that
who's the outsider okay right right that
they were worried about right and
he's terrible okay he fires green and
hires bucky dent
it's it's nice to see him play the field
a little bit i feel like no there's
other talent out there
billy begs him for a more active role in
the team he goes i want to do more i
want to do
starting pitcher billy so george's idea
is to put billy in a uniform and just
have him around
this is a mascot even if it's hanging
out in the owner's box
what sort of weird you're gonna pretend
to be you 10 years ago
what's sort of weird well a lot of
people think it was george's idea of
having a manager and waiting
for a split decision firing oh my god he
has like a like how some people hide
cigarettes
the manager in the wings
and i might have to fire it pinella
now managing the new york yankees for
the rest of the game
in late november after the season's over
george and billy talk in his office
george has a giant mitt
chair and he he makes people seen it
because it
makes him look really small
so let me know if he's a weird guy
they talk in his office then they walk
you're a ball you understand
you're out do you get it yeah you're
tiny no i get it you're in a little mitt
i yeah look at the size of me you're a
big man yeah you're in a small chair
yeah little ball
yeah okay your insides are like string
and stuffing
okay you're excited is there a point to
this meeting yes of course
you're a little ball okay so tiny all
right i'm gonna go
nope get out get get get back
that guy's gone you're a little ball
okay so they talk in his office and then
they go down to the field and then talk
some more
and then they shake hands and the
secret's out
billy v1 is here billy six
is coming if it out does rockies it's a
problem
he's calling he's calling the coaches
it's like he's gonna hire they're in
love yeah it's really crazy and they
just can't
quit they just can't stop it they can't
um he's plan b for the 1990 yankee
season
1990. then um
his mom dies okay and he is [ __ ]
devastated
okay inconsolable a childhood friend
quote he kept saying
i'll never be the same his friend bill
reedy who's now his closest friend
comes up to the farm to hang out you
know my mom died coming here with me
and they head out uh they go out to town
on christmas day
and end up drinking it maury's a local
bar sure
billy was hitting the vodka hard for
some reason the bartender there
was an ex-baseball player it's just all
so crazy
what yeah like cheers that's right yeah
uh he's he's very he's just talking
about spring training he's just [ __ ]
thrilled about spring training starting
he really is yeah you know he's gonna be
a manager yeah they leave the bar
reedy's driving the pickup truck is
going too fast for the icy road and
slides into a ditch
and billy's neck was broken oh [ __ ] he
died on christmas day
1989. jill called his son
his daughter and then george in that
order wow
the irs george is like i'm not gonna
fire him
i think he can still coach this year
what do you think
the irs quickly attached a lien on his
estate for unpaid back taxes oh nice
he would have lived if he had been
wearing a seatbelt wow
thousands came to his funeral saint
patrick's
[ __ ] packed like more people that are
supposed to be in there
street outside thousands of people all
these guys
he really meant something to like a guy
named bob persari came from new jersey
quote
i was a fan of billy all my life he
stood up for the little guy one of us
that's why we're all here also very
diverse crowd
um on
june 6 bucky dent was fired as manager
of the yankees
we're hiring jill [ __ ] it
we are gonna actually employ billy's ear
we found it
cyber died on july 13 2010.
wow that is quite a uh isn't that
[ __ ] crazy
yeah it's crazy that whole that whole
life
is crazy i mean
it's it's like
it's like kill bills the second one is
very different but it's still totally
crazy
yeah there's there's the whole lead
thing
what um leaded gasoline
made people more violent right and crazy
and this is billy was drinking it right
i mean look billy grew up
in a really rough time
his mom's a you know a street sex worker
and
that's that's going to lead to that's
going to lead some fist fights alone
right but you know you're raised by
she's probably an alcoholic i would
imagine right um
so he has a temper problem but
but then he's the guy who cries yeah and
everybody
everybody loves him his [ __ ] teams
love him except for the occasional
rachel jackson but
they everybody loves billy the other
managers who work under
work on them are like he's the smartest
manager that's ever
lived right that's crazy but he's so
[ __ ] volatile yeah no but i mean
there are like
i mean there are
like the whole i mean even players or
athletes like part of the thing
sometimes is
you know finding the way to harness the
talent and focus it because it's just
scattered
yeah and so it's like with someone like
this like the passion
is what's getting your players motivated
and is what's like working your system
but it's also the guy who's going to
[ __ ] chip a reporter's tooth at a bar
that he's black out drunk at like
yeah it's good and bad you know you kind
of just have to
if you're the manager too especially his
situation with steiner it's like
nobody's going to give you baby
corrections
like they're just letting him do
whatever and so
you know he's an old dog no new tricks
really and so he just
but yeah it's really it's crazy
it's a [ __ ] night it's also such a
[ __ ] up time although you know we
obviously live in a [ __ ] up time now
what
but people were so much
the fights the alcohol too i mean that
the level of
alcoholism right but kids don't seem to
fight as much as
we did when we were like people would
brawl all the time
and yeah and i talked to kids now and
it's not a thing like it was
i i mean i i'll bet you that the
you know the idea like it's like road
raging
like you used to be able to talk [ __ ]
when you were driving to people yeah
like you used to be able to you know you
hit a guy with your car on purpose you
deserved it
but um but you used to be able to like
you know be like hey you [ __ ] up back
there but now it's like though
like that now people like i'll kill you
you know you're like oh okay never mind
shouldn't do that so maybe there's some
version
of that like there is maybe but you know
i don't know i think that society was
much more violent back then
yeah but also drunk drunk well that and
that's the other thing you know they
they they drank in the dugout i mean now
that i got in the clubhouse
and everyone was drinking up in the
press box yeah
and then you know in the 70s came around
and they were all doing [ __ ] speed
i mean there was bowls of speed and like
that was helping him get more drunk
yeah i mean it was just yeah i mean they
were using speed to sober up essentially
yeah yeah and now like the thing most
guys seem to be doing is smoking a
little bit of pot you know
how dare they yeah [ __ ] that there's
opiates to get hooked on that's right
um yeah no but um no it's like when you
used to see coaches smoke on the
sideline now you're like what the [ __ ]
is going on
it's just insane or players are smoking
i mean they used to
they i don't think you you can't chew
tobacco anymore but those guys just all
have big wads
yeah no no i mean the the line between
like athlete and regular human was so
much more blurred now you're like though
they're different species of
human but back then you're like hey this
guy's a sky
he like also runs a zamboni company
like you know just like actual humans
um yeah alcoholism is cool
huh alcoholism is pretty cool you've
enjoyed growing up yeah yeah yeah yeah
i like it a lot yeah call me they call
me fan number one
no they i mean they my grandfather was
like a huge
huge alcoholic and my brother when he
tells me stories he's like he was fun
but
he was shit-faced yeah you know like
but that's just how it was it wasn't a
regular to be like drinking at lunch
like every lunch you'd have drinks and
that would not be crazy like if you go
out with someone now and you order
drinks people like is
everything cool like did we talk about
like you would need to be predetermined
that you're getting daydrive
yeah you didn't just drop me like i have
three gin martinis i gotta go back to
the office i'll drive there
i'm gonna be driving back to the office
obviously
yeah it's really crazy um well cool
cool cool cool yeah well there we go
finally
i've always wondered i've always wanted
to hear the opposing coaches
experience on tencent beer night so it's
nice to contextualize that world a
little bit for me
i should read the sources oh yeah yeah
and when you do it say a source is a
source of course
a source is a source of course of course
the source is a source of course
uh main book uh by bill panning
bill main source is a book by bill
pennington
billy martin baseball's flawed genius
uh there's also some new york times
articles
uh and then a meeting article
uh called billy brawl but that one is
very pro reggie and it doesn't really
hold one
but there's some stuff in there there
you go
yeah well but
there you go there's there's there this
is everybody
there you go so signing off this is what
to catch you on the flip side
cut it cut the [ __ ] thing
oh my god you blew that at the end dave
god did you blow that at the end
you